Welcome back to a special
edition of OUTFRONT.
We are live in Ukraine tonight.
This country at war.
For now. 16 months.
And when or if this war ends
what comes next?
Well, for a small view of that, today,
we went back to a town
that we visited
near the start of the war.
This is the village of Andriivka.
It was attacked and occupied by Russians.
It was the most destroyed village
in the entire
region of Kiev,
just destroyed by relentless shelling.
Today, it looks quite different.
There's been a lot of rebuilding.
And one of the people
who's been doing a lot of it.
So much of the cleanup is Olga.
You may remember Olga and Vadim.
We were at their house last year.
This was the cellar,
the root cellar where they stayed
while the Russians were occupying
and staying in foxholes in the back.
This whole area was covered
with pieces of rockets and shells,
ordnance, ammunition.
This was the house over a year ago.
Walking through it,
it was completely destroyed.
But now it's leveled now.
Olga and Vadim are divorced.
It's another casualty of this war.
And Olga has confirmed that her son,
her only child, died fighting for Keith.
It's something she lives with
every single day.
She lives here alone.
And she says she is committed
to staying here.
She says 20% of the village is gone
and is never going to come back.
But she's going to stay here and rebuild.
She describes
it is doing her own
small part to rebuild this country
for her lost son.
This is where she lives now.
She said a local businessman
donated about 13 of these structures
to people in the town.
And this is their temporary.
But this is,
as she said,
pretty much going to be
her permanent home.
As she works
again, she describes in her own
small way to rebuild.
She grows
all of her own food,
her fruits and vegetables in the back,
growing them right on top of the foxholes
where the Russians were living.
Here's the garden
now full of fruits, vegetables, birdsong.
The foxholes here are filled in.
But a year ago,
of course,
they were here with mattresses
that the Russians stole
from the Ukrainians makeshift chimneys.
The Russians in their foxholes
were living a lot
better than the Ukrainians were
hiding in the root cellar.
So now we're in the big
field behind Olga's house.
They're still foxholes back here
And this is one of them.
You sort of just walk amidst
all of this roughage.
And this is one of the main
Russian foxholes that's still here
and go inside.
We understand
this has been cleaned up of mines
and other things.
And I'll just take you inside
well,
you can see the Russians.
They really are.
They really dug it out in here.
Still see the Russian
Marie, the mills, what they were using to
to cook.
They built a makeshift
stove here
even and still,
as I mentioned, these makeshift chimneys.
And this one was pretty sophisticated.
Olga says
this is one of the nicest foxholes
that the Russians built.
And I just want to say again,
the Russians were living a lot
better than the Ukrainians.
But this is the evidence
up here in Kiev region,
of course, is on the front lines.
Ukrainians are camping in the woods.
Entrenched in these positions,
embedded in the woods, fighting even now
to try to free their country.
As we got ready to leave
all this house today,
she turned to cut some flowers
and she brought them to me,
asking me to take them to her son.
Ivan's grave nearby.
It was meaningful to me to be asked
because it mattered to her.
And we went and there we saw
Ivan as a boy and then as a soldier.
And I laid his mother's beautiful flowers
from her garden.
And we thought about this one precious
lost life